new mirror ball new cast and a surprise
return hey guys i'm sarah flanigan and
the new cast of dancing with the stars
season 20 is trending on et now let's
bring out Necia Lucan and her partner
that's right after announcing he would
not be returning because he was
performing in the New York spring
spectacular Derek Hough surprised us all
this all happened literally like two
days ago and you know Harvey Weinstein
has to thank him and and the mining
company and msg for moving mountains and
making as possible so i'll be doing the
show in New York and then flying back
and forth to do the show on Mondays and
that making it happen it will be a
family affair for the house our 5 singer
Riker Lynch will be putting on his
dancing shoes with partner Allison
Holker any advice from your cousin's
julianne and derek hough oh i actually
haven't talked to them yet so i will
definitely be looking for tips patti
labelle will be learning to jive with
partner Artem Chigvintsev Michael say
I'm the first openly gay player to be
drafted in the NFL will be taking his
talents to the ballroom with partner
Peta Murgatroyd bruce willis and demi
moore's oldest daughter Rumer will also
be competing on the show she's partnered
with Val Chmerkovskiy what are your
folks think about you doing the show oh
they're really
also competing for the trophy is suzanne
somers with Tony Dovolani Hunger Games
actress will of shields with Mark Ballas
LMFAO Redfoo with Emma Slater Shark Tank
star Robert Herjavec with Kim Johnson
Carl's jr. model Charlotte with kiel
motsepe and combat veteran Noah Galloway
was sharna burgess but defending
champion Whitney Carson's partner was
m.i.a you know I can't say much oh I can
tell you that you guys need to be super
excited because he's ready to bring it
that's right her partner couldn't Rose I
mean rise so early he could it rosalina
hmm seems like you might be talking
about bachelor crystals but what do you
think about the new cast let me know on
Twitter and make sure you include our
hashtag et now
you